un truc qui ont été notées chez eux chez
eux venus annoncer la construction d'une
nouvelle école le premier ministre a été
accueilli en héros à scott
il y a deux semaines l'établissement
était inondé causant des dommages
estimés à plus de 250 mille dollars au
ministère de l'éducation on me dit que
le plus vite ces deux là mais j'ai comme
objectif de raccourcir ses délais de une
annonce qui interpelle particulièrement
cet élève de 6e année jeunes ce paquet
avait destiné la semaine dernière une
chanson premier ministre pour dénoncer
l'état de son école située en zone
inondable
elle subit les caprices de la rivière
chaudière presque chaque printemps
françois legault a répondu directement
jeune homme dans une vidéo sur facebook
ne répondrai pas qu'une chanson parce
que je faisais un chat mais j'ai bien
écouté j'ai bien regardé les photos
c'est vrai que ça m'ait jamais ce
qu'elle coûte lens parce que là on
rajoute des rouleaux toujours ici puis
leur prochain encore plus d'élèves et
james ne sera pas déçu le premier
ministre confirme que le nouvel
établissement aura 21 classes soit 10 de
plus que l'actuelle l'école sera aussi
construite sur ce terrain loin de la
zone inondable selon les nouvelles
normes dictées par le projet lab écoles
l'infrastructure pourrait donc coûter
plus cher que les 18 millions $ estimé
par la commission scolaire
ça pourrait effectivement plus ce qu'on
veut c'est d'avoir plus d'espacé par
rapport aux anciennes normes qu'on avait
dans le réseau une excellente nouvelle
pour la direction de l'école qui a
essuyé de nombreux refus ces trois
dernières années pour l'obtention d'un
nouvel établissement d'avoir un bâtiment
à la hauteur de ce que mon équipe est
capable de faire c'est un cadeau mais
les défis restent nombreux
si la construction de nouvelles écoles
on devra avoir des locaux mondiale
l'année prochaine de plus c'est ça que
je jase avec ma direction générale parce
que
deux classes qui ont été relocalisés
ailleurs j'ai un groupe supplémentaire
l'an prochain la direction se croisent
également les doigts pour que les deux
crues printanières qui est de restanques
et s'est dit si le déménagement soit
moins dommageable que celle de cette
année ici marc antoine avoir radio
canada scott